[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
segunda profesión pero no menor
involucra me costaba más afectivo y
emocional que es la de ser mamá mamá de
un hermoso príncipe de seis años se
llama máximo y que tiene enfermedad
genética súper rara llamada foxe1 hay
tan sólo 460 extraterrestres como él en
el planeta tierra y la grandeza de su
humanidad combinada con la dureza de su
adversidad entender me permitiera amar
la vida de una óptica muy diferente
[Música]
foxx g1 hola hasta hace poco el único
fox que conocía el canal de televisión y
quizá con algún conocimiento de inglés
su traducción zorro
tremendo solo resultó ser
así hermoso y llorón como lo ven en la
foto así se mantuvo casi hasta el día de
hoy
llegará el diagnóstico de esas cuatro
letras nos llevó tres años recorriendo
médicos genetistas neurólogos hospitales
centros de rehabilitación curanderas
tiene doble pacto de cables y chicos nos
decía una curandera famosa de córdoba al
menos que tengo otra cosa no se lo jugó
para nada y no la estaba errando max y
escondía en esa belleza que lo
caracteriza una mutación en un único gen
vital fundamental para el correcto
desarrollo de su cerebro por el cual su
cerebro no funciona bien
fox' uno chino básico la verdad que
recibir el diagnóstico la noticia del
diagnóstico nos permitió dar vuelta la
página de la incertidumbre es encontrar
paz encontrar respuestas a un montón de
preguntas también entender señales que
máxime daba sin palabras pero nos puso
ante la situación dolorosa inevitable y
tremenda de darte cuenta que tu hijo
tiene una enfermedad severa que va a
impedir sus capacidades toda la vida y
ahí me encontré cara a cara con la
adversidad y nos pusimos a charlar un
rato unos años una vida y la tipa
resultó ser bastante más copada de lo
que parecía
las apariencias engañan
adversidad proviene de la palabra en
latín advertidas que significa la
cualidad de lo adverso quien se
imaginaría vivir la adversidad como una
cualidad
sin dudas puedo decirle que no solamente
es una cualidad sino que es un
inagotable recursos y pensado como algo
positivo pero que puede optimizar
nuestra manera de ver la vida cuando no
hay plan b
no hay de los presentes se imaginaría
tener que proyectar un futuro económico
o proyectar su vida su testamento hasta
su muerte en función de un hijo la
mayoría de las veces el hecho de tener
un hijo o hijos se traduce en
tranquilidad al momento de la vejez
porque van a estar acompañados
independencia crecimiento personal mi
experiencia personal relacionada con
esta incapacidad de máx y con esta
discapacidad de máximo me obligó a
entender la vida de una manera muy
distinta a darme cuenta que muchas veces
la vida no pasa por decisiones acertadas
y correctas y que si podemos enfrentar
esa adversidad de una manera de una
manera correcta seguramente vamos a
poder encontrar un montón de potencial
en ella
les parece que podemos armar un decanato
de condiciones capacidades y recursos
que la adversidad es buena energía de lo
adverso puede permitirnos que le parece
si lo intentamos
como número uno me parece la paciencia
vivir contrarreloj en este mundo que nos
lleva corriendo a todos lados no está
permitiendo desarrollar personas con
capacidades de esperar para encontrar
fruto de sus logros
estamos creando personas con un café con
frustraciones con potencialidades
inconclusas solamente podemos saber
esperar
la paciencia te obliga a ser la
adversidad te obliga a ser paciente te
quite el reloj lo esconde y se ríen tu
cara porque no lo encontrás y con la
intención de frustrar te dice y de
hacerte sentir mal finalmente termina
potenciando un enorme poder y capacidad
que es aplicarle todos los momentos de
nuestra vida y que es la paciencia por
ejemplo simple muy simple contarles que
alimentar a mi hijo me lleva una hora y
media cada una de sus comidas diarias
transferir es obligada paciencia a la
formación de mis residentes en quirófano
me está permitiendo formar capacidades
personas profesionales con las enormes
capacidades y que entienden que la
paciencia también es paso necesario para
ver el fruto de sus logros
como segundo punto podría decirles la
calma
qué difícil que es estar en calma sereno
tranquilo les mentiría si les digo que
soy una persona serena y tranquila los
que me conocen saben que soy hija de
italianos y justamente me caracterizó
por mi intenso temperamento así que mi
familia y mis amigos cuando vean esta
charla seguramente se van a reír mucho
pero creo que la adversidad es la calmen
lo primero que se pierde en la
adversidad pero justamente cuando esta
adversidad forma parte de algo crónico y
cotidiano es lo primero que
desarrollamos y potenciamos porque como
sencillamente porque no hay plan b y
porque de tu calma y serenidad dependen
situaciones momentos personas decisiones
justamente también es una de esas
cualidades que la adversidad disfruta
destruyendo te te le va limando de a
poco con pequeños pequeños piedras en el
camino hasta que en algún momento te
manda como el misil anti calmas que pone
a prueba hasta el mismísimo duda me ha
sucedido en mi vida cotidiana con mi
hijo max y convulsiona muy seguido y una
increíble como se acostumbra a ver a su
niño frágil y hermoso en esa situación
pero ha habido situaciones de salud muy
importantes convulsiones u otros
momentos donde la calma me calma se puso
a prueba pero justamente es esa
adversidad en combinación con la enorme
responsabilidad de estar a cargo lo que
funciona a manera de espinaca para
popeye en lo que es lo que ha referido
calma y serenidad
eso transferido a la vida cotidiana
desde un embotellamiento de tránsito
hasta evacuar un edificio en llamas o en
mi caso en las actividades en quirófano
permite optimizar los logros
tercero el poder de la perseverancia y
ahí no es tanto la adversidad sino mi
sabio y fantástico hijo el que me enseñó
de lo que se trata perseverar perseverar
triunfarás dice un viejo refrán que
repetimos pero probablemente de manera
mecánica sin entender el real propósito
de esas tres palabras
pero seguro es mucho más que insistir en
algo perseverar es poner la mejor
voluntad actitud corazón incansablemente
por eso que queremos lograr concretar
amar
max y tiene un importante problema
motriz lo que hace que no tenga control
de sus piernas y brazos pero así todo
persevera y logra robarnos el celular o
pasar materias en facebook o seleccionar
colores en la tablet su nombre máximo
deriva de la película gladiador así que
él tiene esa chispa gladiador y
perseverante que lo hace brillar y lo
hace diferente
gratitud sería el cuarto de las
capacidades que podemos desarrollar con
la adversidad
la gratitud conduce a la grandeza y
convierte lo que tenemos en más que
suficiente
el trabajo en alegría el caos en orden
y nos enseña que con lo que tenemos
estamos bien la adversidad te obliga a
vivir oa mirar la vida con el cristal de
la gratitud sintiendo gratitud por ese
quince minutos que tuviste que tuviste
en el día para poder terminar de ver tu
serie o esa pasada fugaz con la
peluquería para su tumba sin gratitud
por esas personas que te llamaron por
esos mensajes por por por esas
expresiones de afecto gratitud en esas
pequeñas y cotidianas cosas que tienen
la vida es porque ahí donde se esconde
la verdadera felicidad gratitud como
energía de ir y de vuelta porque darla
te llena el corazón te es en el alma
vivirla vivir en gratitud realmente te
cambia la perspectiva de la vida y
recibir la tele vendor finas alegra
sagradas realmente es una energía es una
buena vibra que bay que viene y que
siempre vuelven más
quinto poder de la empatía
cada vez evolucionamos como humanidad
hacia el individualismo
contradictoriamente tenemos todos los
medios de comunicación la multimedia los
instagram facebook pero a pesar de toda
la manera en que podríamos comunicarnos
y ser empáticos con nosotros estamos
bien siendo cada vez más individualistas
narcisistas egocéntricos le damos like a
la publicación sensible de facebook o de
instagram pero la compartimos mucho
menos tomamos acciones al respecto
y cuando vivía en empatía la vida la
perspectiva de las cosas cambia
completamente porque te das cuenta de
que la simpleza está en esos pequeños
momentos y en esas pequeñas cosas no
sucede por ejemplo de entrar a un local
de ropa con mi niño en su silla y que en
un local de ropa infantil y que la
empleada que nos atienda no nos mires no
lo mires y mucho menos saludarlo para
decir que el derecho de ser
discapacitado lo hiciera invisible
lo mismo nos pasa cotidianamente con el
indigente de la esquina o con el anciano
en su silla de ruedas o con el chico en
parálisis cerebral que no nos que no nos
habla probablemente pasamos por el lado
sin tiene saluda no se imaginan el poder
que tiene el saludo sincero esa pequeña
esa simpleza en la vida de esas personas
porque es ahí en esas simples en esas
pequeñas cosas donde empieza la empatía
y en empatía también es un camino de ida
nutre tanto el alma que no van a querer
volver atrás porque desde la empatía
permeabiliza mos nuestra cabeza y
nuestro corazón en la realidad del otro
realidad con la cual seguramente tenemos
muchos puntos en común otros tantos por
enseñar y un montón por aprender
y esto nos lleva al sexto punto que es
la curiosidad
la curiosidad se interprete o el curioso
se interprete como alguien chismoso
atrevido fuera del lugar no se imaginan
la buena energía de la curiosidad bien
entendida como les permite conectar con
los demás me ha pasado por un poco por
necesidad de información y apoyo de
tener que involucrarme en este camino es
curioso
y de ahí saqué un montón de recursos
medicamentos tipos de la vida cotidiana
terapias para maxi pero es más que nada
conocí a un montón de gente hermosa con
realidades similares a la mía que me
enseñaron un montón de cosas que no
están en ningún libro y que me me
llenaron el corazón y el alma no tengan
miedo de ser curiosos seguir la
curiosidad abre el diálogo permeabiliza
descontractura al otro y nos nos permite
volver al punto anterior nos hace
empáticos si no nos permite
involucrarnos con el otro no le impiden
a sus hijos ser curiosos con un niño
especial muchas veces es muy simple es
muy común que los papás que tienen un
hijo sano y de alguna manera no quieran
o por respeto por lo cualquier situación
no permitan que se involucre con un niño
especial o que pregunte desde ese
internet intercambio de preguntas y
miradas surgen un montón de cosas lindas
empieza el amor empieza la inclusión
empieza la empatía en esos pequeños
gestos dejen que sus hijos sean curiosos
sean ustedes también curiosos charlan
con la viejita de la esquina o con el
que está esperando el bondi en la parada
todas las mañanas es un camino que
también
genera un montón de buena energía
séptimo por de creer como nos cuesta
crear cada vez más exigimos garantías
certezas
estamos perdiendo el poder hasta de
creer en nosotros mismos nos pasa todo
el tiempo en el consultorio por ejemplo
que el paciente venga y que garantías
usted doctora de que esta cirugía va a
salir bien y usted me puede asegurar que
debe andar bien que va estar todo en
orden
la adversidad te enfrenta a dos posibles
caminos resignarse o crear y creer sin
duda es el más difícil porque exige
poner mucho de tu parte exige poner
calma serenidad voluntad curiosidad
bueno un poco todos los demás poderes
potenciados y entrelazados entre sí al
cien por cien
creer termina permitiéndote evolucionar
te permite crecer te permite apostar ni
hablar de que crean en voz de que crean
en tu luz en tu diamante en bruto que
pasa mucho con max y con mi hijo que al
ser un niño no verbal en el no habla y
con todos sus problemas motrices termina
traduciéndose para muchos los
profesionales que lo han atendido en
resignación total no va a caminar total
no va a hablar total no entiende nada
max y no solo que entiende todo
perfectamente sino que también ha
logrado empezar a comunicarse con
dispositivos de comunicación no verbal
está dando sus primeros pasos con
férulas y arneses y va a seguir
creciendo y crecerá gracias a una
familia a una niñera y un grupo de
terapeutas hermosos que han creído que
creen en él crean en ustedes querían en
sus hijos creían en sus empleados en sus
alumnos siempre va a ser mejor que
resignar octavo el poder de resurgir el
dolor que sentí cuando entendí que mi
hijo tan maravillosamente bello tenía
una enfermedad neurológica severa que
iba a condicionar su vida su existencia
siempre toda la vida fue devastador
recuerdo como si fuera hoy el día en que
fuimos al doctor y nos dijo paso a paso
el porvenir de nuestro niño de en aquel
entonces nueve meses me recuerdo
llorando a moco tendido con el alma
destruida en 20 pedazos y con la mente
en negro no en blanco
fueron y son innumerables los momentos
en que llore sentir no tener fuerzas
para nada me encerré en el baño con la
excusa de bañarme pero más que nada para
llorar tranquila y salir de ahí como si
nada hubiera pasado
pero un buen día real más en tu corazón
hecho añicos te das cuenta que funciona
y está mejor que antes quiero empezar a
llenar de amor de paz de alegría de
esperanza empiezan a brillar empiezas a
resurgir la adversidad te da esta
oportunidad y es maravillosa
porque desde desde siempre y cuando
podamos sanar previamente los motivos
que nos llevaron a tocar fondo podamos
tomar impulso salir a flote y respirar
ese aire nuevo que huele a fuerza que
huele a tranquilidad a paz y que nada es
imposible
obviamente cuesta tremendamente lo
primero que hacemos ante situaciones
adversas es preguntarnos qué pasó que
hicimos mal por qué sucedió tal o cual
cosa y si creemos que eso que sucedió en
nuestra vida tenía que pasar seguramente
nuestra tranquilidad va a ser otra en
nuestra energía va a ser otra
la adversidad te enseña posicionarte
desde la sabia mirada de entender que
ese dolor es un trampolín y no un barco
hundido y desde esa manera desde esa
óptica tenemos mirada una mirada
completamente distinta de todas las
cosas que suceden nuestra vida
y esto no depende de la situación límite
o adversa que nos haya tocado transitar
esto está en nosotros mismos depende de
nosotros y es está todo en cómo te hagas
cargo de esa evidencia
noveno el poder de confiar y confiar
confiar es otra de las cosas que esta
nueva era nos fue quitando de a poco no
confiamos en los otros en lo que vemos
al haber hacía de las noticias casi que
no confiamos ni siquiera nosotros mismos
elegimos lo que más conviene desoyendo
muchas veces hasta el mismísimo destino
eso confiar cuesta tremendamente y cada
vez más
qué pasaría si confiáramos qué pasaría
si escucharemos esa voz que tiene
nuestro corazón y que nos dice qué hacer
qué pasaría si entendiéramos que muchas
de las cosas que nos sucedieron tenían
que pasar como parte de un camino de
aprendizaje como parte un camino de
enseñanza como parte un camino de
crecimiento
lo primero que hacemos cuando algo
sucede mal es preguntarnos qué pasó que
hicimos mal donde metimos la pata qué
fue lo que hizo que nos enfermemos o que
tengamos esa ruptura en el trabajo de
ser ese desencuentro con esta persona
qué pasaría si confiamos en que todo lo
que pasó y no pasó pasa y pasará nuestra
vida tenía que suceder
qué es ese dolor llegó tu vida como
parte de un camino de crecimiento que
ese maravilloso niño especial y luego tu
vida como para enseñarte a lo que es lo
simple que es amar cuando dejamos de
lado los mandatos y los prejuicios o
para enseñarte que ese embarazo no llegó
porque tenés que poner tu amor en otra
lucha o tu energía en otro camino
por último el poder del amor
el poder de tu amor decir ricardo
montaner ya en sus canciones
innumerables otras cuanto haya escrito
sobre el amor no siempre es un lugar
pasional y romántico desde
complementarse con el otro para sentirlo
desde recibirlo para darlo
amar sin la expresión verbal y física
que habitualmente estamos acostumbrados
para sentirlo es difícil e implica poner
en juego todos los otros poderes
potenciados entre sí o sea que al revés
el verdadero amor finalmente termina
despertando en nosotros todas esas otras
capacidades creer y confiar perseverar
la gratitud
mi hijo bueno la mente tiene una gran
dificultad en cuanto a lo verbal ya lo
motriz por lo cual su expresión del amor
no pasa por lo verbal ni lo físico pero
es maravilloso cuando con un intercambio
de miradas uno puede encontrar el amor
sin necesitar de nada más es
gratificante es es magnífico y realmente
empezás a entender las simplezas y a la
vez las grandezas que tiene la
posibilidad de amar te empiezas a
empezar a encontrar amor entonces te
haces perceptivo y encontrás amor en
montones de situaciones personas
momentos das cuenta que muchas veces las
palabras están de más
pero también aprendes a no mezclarlas
y realmente te frustras cuando la gente
hace tan complejo algo tan simple como
es amar
por ahí se encuentran a un gran amor y
no se lo dicen por falta de coraje o por
orgullo por miedo o se mueren de ganas
abrazar a sus viejos y decirle todo lo
mucho que lo quieren y besarlo si no lo
hacen porque les gana el orgullo o la
vergüenza o al amigo que estuvo en todas
y que nunca les nunca se lo agradecimos
no pierdan la oportunidad de amar y amar
y expresar su amor finalmente te das
cuenta que después viene un niño no
verbal con una discapacidad severa y nos
enseña lo simple y lo fácil que es amar
amén expresen su amor háganlo llegar a
los que lo quieren no duden en abrir su
corazón porque el corazón nunca se
equivoca dejemos de lado los orgullos y
los prejuicios
el fracaso enseña lo que el éxito oculta
nos decía la doctora estapé en un libro
que les recomiendo que se llama cómo
hacer que te pasen cosas buenas un libro
muy interesante y es muy real esta frase
fracaso enseñó lo que el éxito oculta no
entendiendo el fracaso como paso
necesario para aprender en la vida y ser
lo que somos sino aquel que lo toca sin
vivir una situación de fracaso de
adversidad que lo puede entender como
una posibilidad de evolucionar de pasar
niveles de crecer y de posicionarse en
es un ser humano lo nuevo en nuevas
personas
en la vida es el 10% lo que te sucede y
90% como te lo tomas dice un refrán que
lo han escuchado en algún lado eso me lo
enseñó mi hijo todos los días poniendo
su mejor sonrisa despertándose con su
mejor sonrisa después de las
convulsiones más tremendas o riéndose a
carcajadas simplemente con sus dibujitos
con sus juguetes con su ducha simpleza
grandeza gratitud todo en su mirada con
el solo hecho de la vida simple que le
tocó él desde su enorme adversidad
eligió ser protagonista de su vida tomar
las riendas de su camino
tomemos el timón del barco de nuestra
vida la tormenta en alta mar
probablemente sea inevitable pero no hay
barco que se hunda si el capitán está
convencido de poder sacarlo a flote
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]